In the season of Wishcraft, the tree is missing some of its heads, which, spoilers, is actually
a big deal.
Someone has stolen heads from the Tree of Whispers, and it is the Wanderer's role to
discover the mystery behind who is taking the heads and to what end.
As you progress through the storyline, you work with the coven, and in exchange for your
help, they will give you their own powers, and you can utilize these powers in Season of
Witchcraft.
If you're not familiar, the Tree of Whispers is this ancient tree with heads.
You can come and ask for favors from the tree itself, but it will ask for something in return.
Notoriously, no one has been able to get out of their deal with the Tree of Whispers until
now.
Who is it that's been freeing these heads from the Tree of Whispers, and what are the fugitive
heads themselves trying to accomplish now that they're free from the tree?
And these stolen heads are scattered all around sanctuary, causing chaos and spreading strange
rot, taking over the bodies of the living.
Head rotten are what happens when a head from the Tree of Whispers attempts to graft itself
onto an already living creature to reclaim that life.
They retain some of the tree's power.
Brambles and roots grow along the inside of these creatures, bursting out and causing them
to essentially have a head detach.
And they don't mind sacrificing their living victims in their pursuit to live again.
During the course of the Season of Witchcraft, you're going to work with different witches
to help solve the mystery of the missing heads.
The witches of Hawassar are a coven of witches and chose to serve the Tree of Whispers in exchange
for its power.
At this point, hatred is spreading all throughout sanctuary.
And for the first time, it's managed to launch an attack at the Tree of Whispers.
And though the tree is still standing, it's definitely worse for wear.
And the witches that are bound to the tree have to set things right.
Investigate, hunt down these heads, and through gathering strength in their witch powers to
deal with the encroaching threat, they will be able to uncover what the mystery is.
In exchange for your help, the witches are offering you their witch powers.
And this season, you're going to be able to tap into three major categories of witchcraft power.
Una has Eldritch powers, which are tied to the cycle of life and death.
Eldritch powers are the witch's form of dealing damage directly to enemies in the form of fire
damage, burning damage, shadow damage.
Galena has power over psyche, which is illusion, and seeing the unseen.
Powers of the mind, will, and soul.
And they're the ones that protect you in battle.
Growth and decay powers are powers of the swamp.
Kaden deals with the body, disease and poultices, familiars.
They're the ones that decay your enemies and heal you in battle.
So you might be going for a fire sorceress, for example, and decide that you want to have
ancient mystical frogs helping you in some way.
These are going to be things that you're going to play with to get new levels of power
and unique builds that really are special to just this season.
Every class can use every power for every build.
There is also lost witchcraft power that can be found while you're adventuring.
This is a special witchcraft power that exists outside the purview of traditional witchcraft powers.
So as players progress through the storyline and they complete whispers, they will earn a seasonal currency.
This seasonal currency is used to, one, purchase witch powers and also upgrade your witchcraft powers.
An example of an eldritch power would be a new power, Doom Orb, an ominous orb of pure eldritch energy
that circles you and burns enemies with fire damage.
Doom Orb gets stronger as you slay enemies and will eventually explode.
Doom Orb will also launch itself at enemies if no enemies are near you.
So we do have some returning fan favorites coming back in season of witchcraft.
Players who are fans of our franchise will remember some of these powers are from Diablo 3, specifically the witch doctor.
Firebats is returning from Diablo 3.
Those who have played the witch doctor also remember the hex skill, the toad of hugeness.
However, it's been reimagined for Diablo 4 and Season of Witchcraft.
This is the poison frog servant.
I just think it's adorable and I want to have a murderous pet frog follow me from sanctuary.
Of all the witchcraft powers, something tells me that players are probably going to be the most excited about Piranada.
It's effectively a whirlwind of water and chomping piranhas that will just shred your enemies to pieces.
And yes, it does pull enemies towards it.
So players will be unlocking and upgrading their various witchcraft powers through performing head hunts.
You're going to see that there's an area in the world where the tree of whispers has detected fugitive heads.
The head rotten are there.
You need to go hunt them down.
When they interact with other monsters in the world of sanctuary, best case scenario, they horrifically corrupt that monster to become a new headless form of itself.
Worst case, they actually affix themselves to a monster and become a new boss-like entity that has this ancient rotting head on top of this now puppeteered body.
There is a horror in them, a sort of Frankenstein-esque monster.
So they have more humanoid traits but even stronger powers.
Like flaming swords they're going to be throwing at you or they might be using poison axes that are hurled your way or even shadow spears that tear up the ground.
So these are going to be some new encounters that you've never seen before.
As you perform various whispers in the area, hopefully you see briars out in the world.
These are going to indicate that there's a head rot in there.
If you manage to successfully take down one of the head rotten and claim a fugitive head, this can be returned to the witches at the tree of whispers.
And you're going to get special seasonal sock-tables as a reward.
On top of that, there will be some new whispers out there.
You might have a chance to help a bewitched frog or there might be a lost wisp that needs to find its way home.
As you engage in these whispers, you're going to get reputation with the witches as well as seasonal currency that you can use to unlock and upgrade your witch powers.
So we've seen a lot of great feedback from our players on what are the various features that they most want to see in Diablo 4 to make our game even better.
One that's come up quite a few times is an armory.
When you save a build in the armory, it's going to take a snapshot of everything currently on your character.
Skill tree, paragon boards, your glyphs on those boards, and all of your gear.
Players will be able to access the armory UI from any major city.
You're going to be able to pursue multiple different builds on one class at the same time.
This can be pretty cool when leveling up, but it's especially fun once you get into the end game.
At that point, whenever you find a cool item that, oh man, this is really strong, but not for the build I'm running right now, oh, but you can still use it.
You can still save out separate sets and try to pursue getting really powerful setups of very different versions of your class at the same time.
I am excited of what it could feel like to constantly be swapping between these different builds and seeing which one is the most powerful.
I'm excited for people to just immerse themselves in the season.
Me personally, I'm very likely going to be running a companion druid build with the grow power to have a giant werewolf army.
Hell yes.
We have a quest line that is different and emotionally gut-wrenching.
New wish powers, fugitive heads, new whispers.
Really interesting bosses that have unique attack patterns.
Uniques, legendaries, and new runes for Vessel of Hatred players.
There's a lot to try out here, some builds that have never been present before.
I'm excited to see what players do with it.
Hello, everyone, and welcome to our first Diablo stream of 2025.
We had an excellent holiday break, super relaxed, and very excited to bring you Season of Witchcraft.
Yes.
You might have seen this Tuesday.
We announced Season of Witchcraft is coming on January 21st.
We've got an excellent show for you today.
Today we're joined by some familiar faces.
You know Mr. Charles Dunn.
Welcome.
Hi, I'm Charles.
I'm a game designer on the Live Balance team.
And I'm Aislinn Hall.
I am a systems designer on Live Balance.
Aislinn, great to have you back.
And all the way from Albany, New York, Mr. Dan Tanguay.
Welcome back to the stream.
Hey, everybody.
How's it going?
I'm Dan Tanguay.
I'm the design director for Live Services.
Awesome.
Well, thanks for joining us, Dan.
As you can all see, Season of Witchcraft is upon us.
Huge shout-out to our production team.
We've got some absolutely disgusting heads that we bore from the True Whispers.
You can't see on this guy yet.
I might give him a spin later on, but the teeth on him are absolutely horrible.
Oh, my.
So, yeah, without further ado, to give you a brief overview for the stream, we're going
to walk you through the seasonal content.
So, Season of Witchcraft.
Excited to get into it.
Then we'll head over to some Class and Balance updates, give you a brief preview of some new
uniques coming to the season.
Should be pretty exciting.
And then we'll have some system updates and get into some exciting features coming in
the Season of Witchcraft that have been much anticipated for a long time.
Then stick around because we'll do a Q&A towards the tail end of the stream.
And we'll get into all your questions.
So, I do have Twitch chat open that I'm looking at, and we will be collecting questions throughout
the stream for our devs to answer.
But before we jump into Season of Witchcraft, we do want to cast ourselves all the way back
to the start of December where we had the 2.1 PTR.
Thank you to everyone who jumped into this PTR.
There was a ton of content, and we did have some exciting features.
Like, I've got to ask you, Aislinn.
Like, how did it feel to get the armory finally into this place?
Oh, my gosh.
I've been waiting for so long.
I'm so glad it's finally here.
The armory feels amazing to use.
It's so great to finally have it in the game.
Anyone who hasn't had a chance to try it yet, it's going to be a godsend in Season 7.
You're going to love it.
It's just such a useful tool.
And we'll go more into the details later, but wonderful.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
Oh.
Charles, did you get any feedback on Unix?
Yeah.
Any balance changes?
From the PTR, we got a lot of great feedback on balance and all the new content for classes,
like the new Uniques, new Legendaries, all the tweaks and adjustments to skills.
Your feedback's been invaluable.
Not only, like, feedback written up on social media or on our forums or elsewhere,
but also just, like, in the raw data, the player data, our telemetry has been very helpful
in making sure that this season and every season is as best as it can be when it actually launches.
Yeah.
That's a great point, Charles.
Like, one thing we did want to touch on is even if you don't see your feedback represented
throughout the stream, because we will be touching on different feedback across all
the sections from our PTR, we do still internalize all that feedback and take it through and help,
you know, make decisions throughout future seasons.
So all the feedback is very much appreciated and really does help inform that content.
But yeah, there was a ton to chew on in the PTR.
Like, we had all our Witchcraft powers in there.
Like, there's an absolute smattering of content.
But very excited to throw it over to Dan Tangway.
Can you let us know what players can expect in Season of Witchcraft?
Yeah, let's talk about the Season of the Witchcraft.
There's a lot to cover at this point.
You got a bigger chunk of it than you had in previous seasons in the PTR.
But still, we've got some surprises in store that we want to share with you all.
So let's get started.
First off, the Season of Witchcraft, dozens of heads are missing from the Tree of Whispers.
And so the tree is hell-bent and really just ticked off.
It wants to find them.
I mean, these heads were part of a bargain.
The tree is all about keeping your word.
And now that bargain is broken.
So yeah, the tree is mad.
Full stop.
Now, the Witches have summoned you to the tree.
And they're offering you a deal.
If you can get those heads back for them,
they'll offer you the secrets of Witchcraft.
So that's where we begin.
And the first thing, we're going to have an all-new quest line.
And that new quest line is going to be you unraveling the mystery of those missing heads.
And while you're doing that, like I said, you're going to be earning Wild Witchcraft and Occult Gems.
We have a new activity called Head Hunts.
And that's going to allow you to pursue Whispers, slay Head Rotten,
which is the new enemies, the new family of enemies that we have this season.
And find those missing heads.
In addition to the head hunts, you're also going to have Root Holds.
These are new micro dungeons that allow you to discover bonus Head Rotten and also their bosses.
And then finally, we've got some updates to the season journey that we'll cover,
including a new pet named Dorian, which is a pet raven.
This is our first flying pet, so we're pretty excited about that.
Let's talk about some of the powers.
So Witchcraft, at least as we're defining it this season,
it allows its practitioners to call upon the power of the swamp to do their bidding.
And there are three schools of magic within Witchcraft.
We've got Eldritch Witchcraft, and that's uncanny magic that, you know,
is just weird and bizarre and very of the swamp.
You've got Psyche Powers.
These are powers of the mind and spirit.
And we've got Growth and Decay.
And that's magic that both heals and harms your enemies.
I'm going to take a look at it.
Some of these in action.
So first up, we're going to have Eldritch Powers once we get our clip going.
And right here, we're seeing that we've got Fire Bats,
which is a classic power from the Witch Doctor that we brought back this season,
paired up with Doom Orb.
Next up, we've got some Psyche Powers here.
And we're using Vengeful Spirit, which is kind of hanging around you
and zooming between enemies.
And the Aura of Lament, where you see these psychic projections of hands come out of the ground
and slow your enemies.
And finally, we've got Growth and Decay magic.
And you watch right there.
Your wolves got really big all of a sudden.
That's Grow magic.
And that's been paired up with the Poison Frog, which you see in the corner,
wailing away on the head rotten there.
So those are some good examples of the types of magics that you're going to be able to use in this season.
And you'll start seeing them sprinkled all throughout the rest of the clips that we're about to show you.
Next up, let's talk about the head hunts.
So I said before, the tree was really mad, right?
Because it's missing its heads.
And so what it's doing is actually calling out all new whispers.
And it's just furiously, furiously searching for these heads.
But it can't do it on its own.
So when it calls out a particular zone, because it knows roughly where the heads are,
it calls its agents to help it out.
And you're one of the tree's agents.
So you can go and solve some of those whispers and get rewarded for them.
Now, the head hunts are special zone takeovers that complement the helltides.
So folks on the PTR called them witch tides.
Sure, you can call them that.
But the idea is that these aren't just replacing helltides.
They're there to supplement them in terms of what you can do in the overworld.
Now, these are going to be swarming with head rotten, those enemies we talked about before.
The head rotten are monsters that have fallen under the influence of the missing heads.
And the heads have transformed them in really grotesque ways.
Now, these head hunts, like I mentioned, are going to feature all new whispers mixed with some existing ones as well.
Completing a whisper unlocks what's called an exposed root.
And that gives you a chance of actually triggering what is a cocoon.
And these uprooted cocoons have a chance of then spawning a head rotten boss.
So every time you complete a whisper, you've got a chance at triggering a boss.
And occasionally a boss will spawn from one of these and then everyone in the zone can work together to try and take down that boss.
And if you're really lucky, that boss will have one of the missing heads associated with it.
So let's take a look at some of this in action here.
Now, first up, we're going to check out one of our new whispers.
This is a shepherd whisper.
This is allowing you to, you know, guide some of these innocent wildlife in this area to safety.
You know, very simple.
But, you know, the witches want to make sure that no one's harmed by the head rotten.
Next up, we've got some villagers that are trapped in Bramble in an Entangled Whisper.
And so you're trying to defeat all the enemies around there in order to free the villager there.
Following that, we're actually going to get a view of one of the exposed roots as it transforms into this uprooted cocoon.
And so much like some other open world boss fights, there's going to be some combat leading up to the boss spawning.
And that first cocoon actually didn't have a boss in it, but you still got some rewards from it.
So we're going to see if this second cocoon has a boss in it.
So we're, you know, continuing to clear head rotten.
And indeed, a boss does spawn.
Now, unfortunately, it's not a boss with a missing head.
This is a headless husk.
But still, it's going to be pretty rewarding to defeat this.
So hopefully everyone in the area realizes that, you know, there's a boss in the air and they're going to come help you defeat this.
And yeah, that is a good peek at what head hunts are going to be.
But let's go back to the tree now because I really want to take you through some of the steps on how to learn new witchcraft.
So let's talk about that.
So the first thing that's really important when you want to learn new witchcraft is that you're always going to be earning covenants favor from completing whispers.
And that's going to unlock new witchcraft at certain tiers of the coven favor board.
Now, additionally, as you're killing those head rotten that I showed you before, you're going to be earning restless rot.
Now, restless rot is something that you can offer as proof of a kill to the altar to earn that new witchcraft.
And then you can use it also to upgrade your witchcraft directly in your UI.
One final note I want to make here is that we decided to use witchcraft and the seasonal powers as a way to help boost your alts.
So that means that whenever you upgrade and unlock a piece of witchcraft, that's going to stay upgraded and locked for all your characters on your account for the rest of the season.
So it's going to be a great leg up for, you know, trying new characters in the future.
But let's take a look at some of this in action.
All right. So here we are in the Tree of Whispers area and we're looking at the coven rep board.
And we'll see right up here that on rank seven, you actually unlock some more witchcraft.
So we're going to go over to our altar now.
Now at the altar, we're going to take a look at a list of things that you haven't learned yet.
And each of these costs restless rot to earn.
And so you're going to learn grow.
And now grow has appeared in your witchcraft inventory to the right.
And you're also going to look at upgrading abyssal resonance.
That was a bit of a mouthful.
And we can upgrade it from rank three to four by just plying the restless rot directly.
But head hunts aren't the only places that you're going to be able to find head rotten.
And let's go.
Actually, no, I'm skipping ahead.
Let's talk about forgotten altars first.
So there's a bit of a twist on earning some of your witchcraft.
Not all the witchcraft that you can learn is actually known by the witches of Hawazar or the tree for that matter.
Some of it has just been lost to the world.
And so these take the form of lost powers that you can find on forgotten altars out in the dungeons of Sanctuary.
So as you're adventuring through your dungeons, you will find some lost powers that you can't get anywhere else.
And so it should be pretty exciting to stumble across one of these.
Can't remember if there's a clip or not here.
So let's take a look.
There it is indeed.
And so real quick, you know, going through a dungeon, you see a forgotten altar, you interact with it, and then a new power is unlocked.
Now, the cool thing about these is that if you find more altars, you can upgrade your powers by doing this.
But you can also upgrade them through spending a premium price of restless rot.
So you've got a couple options for upgrading these once you're able to find them.
Now we're going to talk about the root holds, I think.
So root holds.
Root holds are micro dungeons.
And so these micro dungeons are home to some of the head rotten and the head rotten bosses and the missing heads.
They've gotten a little wise to what the tree's up to.
So they're trying to hide underground.
And so each of these contains a really concentrated population of head rotten and their rewards.
And they require a new type of sigil called the whispering wood in order to access.
And so these drop from whisper caches.
So as you complete those whispers, you'll get more access to root holds, as well as silent chests, which actually are pretty common in the head hunt areas.
So let's take a look at a root hold.
First off, we're going to open our inventory.
And in there is going to be a whispering wood.
And we're just going to trigger that like we would any nightmare dungeon.
And then we're going to teleport right into our root hold.
And I can take you through a little bit of that.
All right.
Now we're in the root hold.
And we're going to come upon a couple of interactions.
Actually, four.
These are rites and ceremonies.
These are interactions that allow you to increase the challenge in the root hold in order to get more rewards.
And if it reminds you a little bit of hell breaches, well, it is pretty similar.
But unlike those, you can actually do multiple rites and ceremonies instead of just one.
And when you take those on, then all the enemies and all the interactions afterwards have been impacted.
And so we're going to fight through some of the head rotten here.
Like I said, root holds are a pretty good spot to get a concentrated dose of them.
And you also get a number of guaranteed roots that you can try and uproot as well, which is great.
We'll watch a little bit more of this.
And then we'll culminate with a boss.
One more battle first.
But I'll say that each root hold is guaranteed to have a boss at the end,
which is nice if you want to start really trying to grind to get your missing heads.
Now let's take a look at the boss.
Oh, well, this boss actually has a head.
So that's pretty cool because a lot of them don't.
So we're going to kill that boss and that boss is going to drop a missing head.
And we're actually going to go take it back to the Tree of Whispers now.
So taking it back to the Tree of Whispers, we're going to talk to a witch.
And we're going to be able, in return for giving her this head, craft an occult gem.
And this gem, I think we're going to craft as an Elder Sigil.
And we're going to be able to slot that into one of our rings.
So let's do that right now.
Here we go.
And the Elder Sigil is not only going to provide us some defense like you would get from your diamond or skull that you've slotted into a ring or a talent, not a talisman.
Yeah.
But also, it's going to give you some additional bonuses above and beyond that.
But I'm dancing around it.
What are occult gems?
And so let's talk a little bit more about what occult gems are at this point.
So occult gems are special socketables.
And these socketables are going to really help you fine-tune your build after you have kind of a good foundation of witchcraft.
Now, they're crafted, like you saw using the missing heads returned to the Tree of Whispers.
They can only be slotted in jewelry slots, though.
Your talismans and your rings.
And they only last for the season.
Now, when items transfer to the Eternal Realm, they disappear forever.
And they build on top of your witchcraft powers.
You know, they're going to provide item and skill bonuses for certain witchcraft combinations.
So if you really like the Piranado, for example, you're going to be investing in Hex and Aura.
And if you invest a lot in Hex and Aura, it probably is wise to try and find an occult gem that also builds on top of those things as well.
And that'll really allow you to fully enhance your build while you're entering and then playing through the endgame.
All right.
So we've talked a bit about occult gems.
While we were putting all this together for Season of Witchcraft, we also saw some really good opportunities to improve the quality of life of the Whisper Loop.
So let's talk through a couple of those right now.
First off, we've updated the town area around the Tree of Whispers.
Previously, it was kind of small.
It was, you know, home to a number of outcasts.
And that group of outcasts has grown this season.
Not only do the witches make home there, but there's a couple of new people there that provide additional services.
And we've also actually put an extra armory in there, too, so you can make use of that.
Now, while you're out in head hunts, we've also added a new feature called the Raven of the Tree.
And this allows you to basically make submissions to the Tree of Whispers, turn in your grim favor in order to be able to get a cache immediately on the spot instead of having to return to the, you know, the Tree of Whispers itself.
And, you know, it's convenient, sure, but it also allows you to really stay in the moment if, for example, you know, a new boss is triggered or something like that from an uprooted cocoon.
And you want to join in that, you go over to the Raven of the Tree, turn in your grim favor, and then get right back into the battle again.
And finally, we've got some ancestral caches.
These are a new type of cache that we've added that guarantees an ancestral item.
And we wanted to make sure just that the Whisper Loop had, you know, a full range of items that it could drop.
So we're pretty excited to be able to share all of these with you, as well as some new improvements to the Season Journey.
So let's talk through those real quick.
Now, with the Season Journey, we realized that a lot of casual players use the Season Journey as a way to figure out what to do next.
And we also realized that our early chapters hadn't really been helping the casual players as much as we would have liked.
So we've reworked a lot of those early objectives to help casual players more because we want to see more of them get into the endgame.
Now, the later chapters, though, didn't feel especially challenging to us.
So we've tried to improve that.
Chapter 7 especially, we've reworked to really provide some more aspirational goals for players.
And this is something that we're just going to continue working on in future seasons as well.
Now, we've asked you to do a lot more in terms of the objectives.
So we wanted to make sure we gave you a really great reward, too.
So this is where you can earn Dorian the Raven.
And like I said at the top, this is our first flying pet, which is pretty awesome.
So let's take a look.
You know, I am pretty excited to get Dorian.
I have a feeling that flying pets are pretty much going to be my new favorite moving forward.
So, yeah, definitely looking forward to this one.
Oh, yeah.
Dorian's going to be wonderful.
You know, Ravens love shinies.
So him picking up your gold is just perfect.
Right on.
Yeah.
Green point.
And finally, I think I'd like to chat through some PTR stuff.
So Charles is going to cover a lot of the updates we made to the powers and occult gems because that's what his team focused on.
But the seasons team really focused on some of the head hunts and systems and took a lot of your feedback and really tried to improve the game prior to launch.
So here's a couple of things that I just want to cover real quick.
First off, the multiplayer head hunts felt overwhelming for a lot of new players.
And so we've done a number of things to tweak the head hunts to make sure that they don't feel as overwhelming.
First off, we've, you know, made some targeted reductions to the number of elites.
There were just a lot of elites on the PTR.
And so you're still going to have a lot of monster density as you're fighting through these head hunts.
But hopefully this will make things a little more manageable because we also had to reduce the number of, not the number of bosses, but the frequency at which they spawned.
So we've got bad luck protection to make sure that, you know, you will eventually see a boss spawn as you're playing through a head hunt.
But we had to dial that down just a little bit because they were coming up quite, quite often.
We've also reduced the number of low value item drops.
You know, we had heard from a number of you that you were spending more time picking up a lot of items that really weren't good instead of actually battling the head rotten, which is what we want you to do.
We've also reduced the number of active head hunt zones from five to four.
And then finally, we're going to add a new HUD element.
A number of folks have pointed out that it wasn't really clear that completing whispers was the thing that actually triggered the roots and then the cocoons.
And so we've got a HUD element that will definitely illustrate that better.
Unfortunately, that's not going to come till release 2.1.1, which is going to be roughly two weeks out from launch.
Now, head rotten, especially bosses, were not challenging enough.
So that's another thing that we've looked to address.
We've increased the head rotten barrier effect.
Previously, it was around half health.
We've made that full health now.
And we gave the head rotten a very small percentage of damage reduction as well.
We've given you a lot of cool new powers and form of witchcraft to play with.
We want to make sure the head rotten serve is a good challenge for you as you're building out your witchcraft powers.
Next up, head rotten bosses were just not rewarding enough across the board.
So we've increased their rewards to a level that's closer to a blood maiden than what they were previously.
And then finally, some players didn't quite understand how to earn an upgrade witchcraft.
So we made some changes to help with that.
Each alter is going to contain the same inventory now instead of having unique inventories.
And that way, you don't need to try and figure out which alter you need to go to in order to learn something.
And we've also rewritten a lot of the tooltip descriptions to make sure that we're very clear about where you can go to get things.
But yeah, I think that covers it for PTR learnings.
And I'm trying to think if there's anything else, but I think I'll pass it back to Irvine.
No, I think you covered all of it, Dan.
That was incredible.
That was an absolute ton of content.
There's just so much to dive into with this season.
I think I can speak for everyone between root holes, witchcraft powers, occult gems.
There's just so much in the mix to dive in and get used to.
And it all kind of comes back to head hunts that you can kind of use as a zone to get into all the content, which is super exciting.
So Dan, thanks so much for walking us through all of that.
I know we've got more details coming out in our patch notes following the stream.
And we do have some of those witchcraft powers already existing in our blog.
So if you want more information on those, you can check those out.
But Dan's going to stick around because we will be bringing Dan back for our Q&A section at the end of the stream.
So if you have any questions on Dory and the Raven or on witchcraft powers, occult gems,
or anything to do with Season of Witchcraft, please drop those in chat and we'll grab them throughout the stream.
But for all of you who are kind of theory crafting and build crafting and thinking about like,
okay, what's my play style going to be for Season of Witchcraft?
You're probably already thinking about the different occult gems, the different witchcraft powers.
But to finish off that equation, of course, you need to get all the balance updates for the season.
So Charles, can you take us through what's coming?
Of course.
Yeah, I'd love to talk about how you're going to attack these head rotten.
Like, what is your build going to look like and what are some of the new uniques and legendaries that you're going to get to play with in this season?
First, before we get into each individual class, I want to talk about some of our broader initiatives on the class design side
that kind of affect every class in some way.
Specifically, I wanted to talk about how we did some ultimate skill updates in this patch.
For ultimate skills, we're now able to get skill ranks on them starting in Season 6, the previous season.
But now once you get them up to rank 5, you're going to get a special bonus.
And we found these to be really flashy and fun on the PTR.
People love playing with ultimates and you get to cast them more often.
They've got more effects.
They had some scaling ways to scale their damage with these rank 5 bonuses sometimes.
We did find that some of those exact scaling numbers were a little on the higher side.
They were a little bit more powerful and kind of crowding out non-ultimate builds.
We love that people are playing these and we want them to be powerful.
But there are certainly some times when it's a little too much and it feels like you can't play anything else.
So we are taking a pass across the board on some of those ultimate scalians to bring them down just a little bit.
But we still expect them to be very powerful and very fun.
Secondarily, we've got the summons update.
This was a big pass across summons from Necromancer, their skeletons, druid companions.
Rogue Shadow Clone is a big one.
Oh, yes.
And then even Sorcerer Conjurations and the Barbarian Ancients even.
So for the summons update, without getting too technical into it,
essentially what happened was all of the damage that your summons do is going to be attributed to the player
and not to a separate entity that's kind of separated from you.
And what that ultimately means is that all of those summons will now inherit your damage bonuses more consistently.
Anything that says you deal increased damage affects your summons.
Just out of the box, it works for everything.
It's just more consistent interaction across the board.
Any of your lucky hit effects that says, hey, you've got a lucky hit chance to stun an enemy.
All of the damage from your summons also can trigger that now.
And this is great for consistency across the board.
Previously, it was sometimes inconsistent.
What would work with what?
And I'm particularly excited about Shadow Clone, as we'll talk about in the Rogue section coming up.
But that was one that historically really never hit the mark for an ultimate skill.
And with this new update, we think Shadow Clone is going to really live up to the promise of really duplicating your actions
in a way that feels meaningful and does tons of damage exactly like you'd expect it to.
Oh, it's going to be very powerful.
I'm looking forward to it.
And summons truly are just an extension of you now in all of your power.
They're inheriting all of that properly, and they're going to blast.
It's going to be great.
Absolutely.
The one last kind of big picture item that we took away from the PTR was about crowd control effects.
We noticed that there is a whole lot of what I call incidental crowd control effects,
things that happen from lucky hits or procs, specifically from the worldly fortune tempering manual
that gives you lucky hit chance to stun or chance to freeze an enemy,
as well as particularly from the fist of fate unique item.
We found that it was often the most common way to build your character in the late game
was to really stack up these effects, and then you're just applying a lot of crowd control
on this lucky hit cadence rather than actively pressing crowd control buttons or really opting into it.
And we do think that once it gets to a certain point of that, it can make our combat less engaging,
where enemies just randomly get stunned or frozen without you really having too much input into that.
But then it also makes it very frustrating when you don't lucky hit,
and an enemy hits you that you expected to have got hit with this.
So we're looking to potentially address that in a future season or future updates.
We don't have any changes regarding the crowd control here in Season 7,
but it's one of those examples of the learnings that we're going to take forward to future seasons
and potentially look at improving this so that we can make our combat feel that much more engaging
and actually get a little bit of back and forth between you and the enemies a bit more than there currently is,
especially in the hyper late game situation when your characters are really maxed out.
So with that in mind, let's get on to some of the individual classes, starting with the Barbarian.
So the Barbarian on the Season 7 PTR was performing quite solidly.
We were pretty happy with where Barbarian landed.
We are really excited about Hammer of the Ancients and this Earthquake build with the new unique,
which we'll show in a moment.
We do think the Hammer of the Ancients part of that maybe could use a little bit more numerical buffs,
so we threw some buffs there, as well as to Whirlwind.
That build was definitely falling a bit behind some of the other builds.
But on the whole, we definitely expect Barbarian to be really powerful and a strong option going forward.
Let's take a look at that new unique item, the Mantle of Mountain's Fury.
Oh, yes.
This empowers your Hammer of the Ancients to cause a seismic line,
and if that line hits an earthquake, it's going to explode that earthquake for massive damage and big fire explosions.
Looks so sweet.
It's very intense.
Very powerful, and right on the Barbarian fantasy of just hitting things with big weapons, making earthquakes, making explosions.
Yeah, that's ludicrous.
I love it because the flavor of Hammer of the Ancients is like, hit the ground and smash it.
And this is just taking that and amplifying it by like 100 times.
Oh, absolutely.
So really excited for this and to see how this build performs in Season of the Witchcraft.
Up next, we've got the Sorceress.
So the Sorceress, kind of in contrast to the Barbarian, was by far the weakest class on the PTR.
No getting around that.
We definitely made some adjustments going into this season that we think maybe overshot and brought Sorceress down a little further than we'd be happy with.
Particularly changes to Conjuration and Burning bonuses.
We're happy with how that affected build variety, but the overall power level suffered.
So with that in mind, we're going to do a lot of buffs on, mainly on the passive effects for the class, to really kind of bring all of their numbers up by just a little bit across the board.
I specifically wanted to call out our changes to Searing Heat and Icefall.
These are legendary Paragon nodes that previously were very build specific, like you would only use Searing Heat in a Burning build.
We've made some tweaks to it where it's still good in a Burning build.
It's probably better.
But it also has some applications across all builds and all damage types.
So these will just be a little bit more generically applicable, but still very good for the build that they were initially intended for.
Right.
With that in mind, I want to show some of the updates to Firebolt enchantment.
This is one that we had reworked as part of those Burning changes, and we thought even on the PTR it wasn't quite hitting the mark.
So now, dealing Burning damage, if you take this enchantment, will have a chance to heal you for some of your maximum life, which it already did.
And it also unleashes a bonus Firebolt onto a nearby enemy.
So that you can see in this clip here, when enemies are burning, they're just randomly firing off some extra Firebolts to nearby enemies that can really help to spread that Burning and take down big packs.
Yeah, it's its own little chain Firebolt now.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Also, I want to highlight some of the new uniques coming in this season.
So Sorceress has two.
The Strike of Stormhorn is a unique focus that's going to modify your Ball Lightning to give you Super Ball Lightning sometimes.
So it'll always fire out straightforward, and it's a little bit faster.
And occasionally, you'll get the Super Ball Lightning, which will explode for a big chunk of damage at the end in a cone shape, and also stun enemies.
It's kind of like going bowling.
Exactly.
And you get a Strike of Stormhorn.
Alternatively, you could take the other unique focus that is being introduced in this season, Okun's Catalyst, to kind of play Ball Lightning the way it's often been played in the past, with this gravitational effect.
We've done some reworks on the gravitational aspect that previously did that, and now it will be in this unique, where the Ball Lightning will orbit around you and do damage to enemies who are close by.
You really want to get close and in that action, whereas with Strike of Stormhorn, you're playing at a little bit more of a range.
Right.
We really like how we're doing these paired uniques, where you kind of have a choice.
Hey, what focus do I want to use?
They are going to be mutually exclusive.
You can't have both.
They're in the same slot.
But that's because they're so different, and they're different play styles.
But we think putting these into different uniques gives us the space to really live up this fantasy, give you lots of affixes and bonuses that make it as powerful, and really to help enhance that fantasy that we're hoping to play.
Yeah, and Oaken's Catalyst really gives you that transformative Ball Lightning experience, which is like the orbiting Ball Lightning.
But Strike of Stormhorn kind of just amplifies the original Ball Lightning experience, which is just shoot it out and have it explode in this magnificent blast of energy.
So I love that we are allowing both of those to shine.
Absolutely.
All right, on to the next class.
We've got the Druid.
So the Druid on the PTR did have one bugged build.
One of their legendary Paragon nodes was causing their damage to scale way higher than we intended.
Occasionally we'd even kind of break the game and go, you'd see negative damage numbers.
Definitely not intended.
We fixed that bug.
But despite that, we think Druid on the whole was still in a solid place even without that.
We've made a number of adjustments and reworked the Blurred Beast aspect.
This is one that we had tried out a rework on the PTR, and it wasn't quite hitting the mark.
It wasn't quite as engaging to play as we had hoped, so we did a rework to it to help improve the Shred builds for Werewolf.
Additionally, I wanted to highlight some of the Spirit Boon updates.
These were the Druid class mechanic.
You get these Spirit Boons.
Historically, they've been a little bit falling behind, and we've done some big buffs here to make them really powerful.
I especially like the Gift of the Stag.
It's my favorite one.
It gives you passive Spirit generation every second.
Yeah.
That really helps smooth out Druid's early game in particular when they're struggling to really get their resource engine online.
They were definitely one of the slower classes early on, and I think this update to the Spirit Boons is going to really help that.
Yeah, totally, and that's just such a great example of how the update is going to help them because Druids have typically struggled with generating Spirit in the early game,
and so having more access to that is going to help a ton.
Yeah.
Let's take a look at a clip of the new Blurred Beast rework.
So on the PTR, it would do some bonus strikes based on how far you traveled.
Now your Shred will just always have a chance to land additional strikes, but it's going to roll that randomness four times.
So if you get real lucky on your Shred, you're going to hit so many times on that target,
which really helps amplify the fantasy of werewolves striking fast, striking multiple times.
Yeah, this aspect is super fun to play, and I absolutely love what the art team did with this,
combining the mechanics of that feedback on the extra strikes with the actual additional slashes going out.
It looks awesome.
All right, on to the Rogue.
So the Rogue was a very strong class on the PTR.
We thought it was in a great spot, very powerful, particularly with Reign of Arrows.
Yeah.
Reign of Arrow builds were already a pretty common, pretty powerful build before the season,
but with the new changes to introduce the additional scaling damage on it, they were just absolutely top.
Yeah.
So I will say that, of course, as part of addressing the ultimate changes across the board,
we did bring down the scaling a little bit on Reign of Arrows,
but we do think that it's still going to be a very compelling choice.
Rogue and ultimate skills are going to be just fine going forward into the season.
It'll be good.
Also, I wanted to talk a little bit about Shadow Clone.
I know I teased that earlier with the summons update.
Shadow Clone was probably one of the biggest updates in this season to really make sure it worked with all of your damage,
all of your bonus effects, all of your procs,
and especially work with a lot of your legendary effects that modify your skills.
So previously, if you had, say, if you're using Flurry,
and you had the aspect of encircling blades that would cause Flurry to hit all around you,
your Shadow Clone wouldn't know that you have that.
It would just kind of attack like a normal Flurry.
With this update, it'll now copy all of your legendary effects.
Just as if you were casting the skill yourself,
it comes from the Shadow Clone,
and it works with all of those modifications.
And that's huge.
Absolutely.
It's a lot more damage.
Yeah.
I really think, you know, I love Reign of Arrows,
I love Death Trap, the other ultimate options on Rogue,
but I think Shadow Clone, it's time to shine.
It is.
Shadow Clone hit the gym.
Absolutely.
Let's take a look at a clip of the new Shadow Clone in action.
So here we've got the aspect of encircling blades,
the Flurry that I mentioned earlier.
Oh, baby.
Doing the big AoE around both you and the Shadow Clone.
Additionally, with twisting blades,
when they come back and orbit around you,
that Blade Dancer's aspect,
they'll also come back and orbit around your Shadow Clone.
Wonderful.
Charles, you're going to make me do a Rogue Flurry Shadow Clone build this season.
Yeah, it should be great.
Let me know how that works out.
All right, on to the Necromancer.
So the Necromancer was probably the class that benefited most
from a bug with the scaling of the ultimates.
As I mentioned, there were some scaling with different stats.
And whenever there was two stats involved,
particularly on Army of the Dead,
then it was actually increasing the damage far higher than we had intended.
So we have fixed that bug and we've addressed it.
But with that in mind,
Necromancer is definitely the biggest benefit of the Summons update.
I know Shadow Clone is great,
but, you know, Necromancer is the Summons class.
Of course.
So they have by far the most.
All of their skeletons and their golems
are now going to much more consistently interact
with your lucky hit procs,
your bonus damage effects,
anything that, you know, increases your damage output
will also increase the damage output of your minions.
And on the whole,
we really expect the Summon Necromancer
to be at its peak going into this season.
Amazing.
So channeling my Adam Jackson here.
Minion stomps.
Minion stomps are absolutely going up this season.
For sure.
Additionally, we've got some new,
just like the Sorcerer,
we've got two uniques that talk to Bloodwave.
The unique, or the legendary,
sorry, the ultimate skill.
We've got two different unique pants
that can enhance your Bloodwave in different ways.
Let's take a look at a clip of those.
So first we've got Indriel's Memory.
And this is going to be kind of your standard Bloodwave.
You know, it still flies forward,
but when it hits the end,
it's going to trap enemies in a Bone Prison.
Additionally, it modifies your Bone Spear
to also become a Blood skill.
Now you've got a Blood Spear.
Right.
And with the inherent affix here,
casting your Bone Spear reduces Bloodwave's cooldown,
it really promotes the synergy between Blood and Bone.
And you're going to get a nice loop of,
hey, cast the Bloodwave,
and then trap them in that Bone Prison.
Hey, that's perfect for lining up this Blood Spear.
And by casting that,
you're going to reduce the cooldown in a Bloodwave
to be ready for the next pack.
Right.
This unique alone really makes Blood and Bone,
like a Blood and Bone build,
come alive, which is cool.
Absolutely.
The alternative,
you could use Kissimmee's Legacy.
This one changes Bloodwave.
Instead of one wave going forward,
you've got two crashing in from both sides.
And it's going to pull enemies towards you.
And when it hits,
it's going to do a big pulse of damage in the middle.
That's awesome.
It's so cool.
It's very transformational in the way you think about it,
the way you position it,
and what your use case is, right?
It's not for pushing enemies away.
It's for bringing them in close
and really wanting to be in the thick of combat there.
Yeah, it really makes me think about
like a more melee or close range centered Necro build,
whereas Endira's Memory makes me think about
a ranged Necro build.
Absolutely.
This pulls them in,
perfect for setting up a Blood Surge
to hit enemies right around you.
So definitely looking forward to see,
you know,
a Bloodwave being played in a number of different ways
in this new season.
And finally,
we've got the Spiritborn,
of course,
our newest class,
which is very strong.
It was very strong in the previous season
or what's currently live on season six.
We did some adjustments
to some of the bug interactions
that was causing their damage to scale
way higher than intended,
as well as a handful of nerfs across the board
going into the PTR.
That being said,
on the PTR,
we still found them to be a very strong class,
arguably still the strongest.
So with that in mind,
we didn't really make too many changes.
We really wanted to make sure
that we brought some of the other classes up
to that level,
and we think the Spiritborn is in a good place.
So there was actually a very minimal amount
of numerical adjustments
to Spiritborn going into this season.
With that in mind,
I wanted to highlight the Razor Wings build.
There's a new unique item,
the Sunstained War Crozier,
as well as a new aspect,
the aspect of Endless Talons.
That's going to really help
enhance this Razor Wing build.
I think we've got a clip of that.
So we've got the Sunstained War Crozier,
and that's going to enhance
all of your focus skills.
They automatically benefit
from all of our upgrades.
You don't need to invest skill points in there.
And by casting it,
you increase the damage
of your potency skill,
your Razor Wings,
whenever you're casting focus skills.
As Razor Wings is a potency skill.
Yes, absolutely.
Yeah, so we're really looking forward
to seeing how this Razor Wings
was maybe a little bit underrepresented
on the current season,
and we're really looking forward
to this unique
and the new Legendary
to really bring it up to par.
All right, so that covers
our class updates.
And once again,
I kind of went at high level
for each class
because the actual number
of changes were rather,
you know,
there's a lot more
that we didn't want
to just throw up
all the numbers
for every single class.
So I kind of painted
a broad picture.
Make sure you check out
the patch notes
for the actual changes
that should be coming
right after this stream.
Yeah, the patch notes
are massive,
so buckle up for those.
They're quite long.
If we went through those,
that would be like
a four-hour stream.
Right.
But dive into those
post-stream, absolutely.
Luckily,
for some of the Occult Gems
and Witch Power updates,
we could fit kind of
all the changes
onto the side.
So we're going to go
into a bit more numbers here.
So let's take a look
at what we made updates
on the Occult Gems.
I think on the whole,
Occult Gems were pretty strong.
They were really hitting
that mark of,
they were appealing
to put into your jewelry,
the rings and the amulet.
And they gave you
a lot of defense
and a lot of other bonuses.
Some of the bonuses,
maybe a touch high.
So we brought some of them
down by just a little bit.
Right.
We still think on the whole,
these are going to be
really exciting,
moments to be able
to craft these
once you get those heads.
I really like to call out
the update to Witching Hour
here at the end.
This is a Occult Gem
that modifies your core skill
to gain the Eldritch Tag.
And that enables
some really interesting synergies
that you'll be able
to explore once you get
your hands on
the full Witchcraft system.
But when it had a timer
of five seconds
in order to do this,
it was really hard
to build around.
Yeah.
And now reducing that
down to one second
means you can much more
consistently benefit
from this effect
and it really opens up
the build possibilities
with the Witching Hour
Occult Gem.
It was a bit too slow-paced
for how fast Diablo 4
is right now,
but with one second
on the timer,
it should be a lot
more playable.
For sure.
We've also made some updates
to the Witch Powers
themselves.
And for the Witch Powers,
we think in general
these were probably
a touch weaker
than we'd like.
So across the board,
there's some
numerical improvements,
especially on the
Poisoned Frog Servant.
My favorite,
the little frog pet.
The wee beastie.
Hell yeah.
Oh man,
he got big buff.
Love that guy
following us around
and spitting the poison
and exploding
if he ever dies.
Yep.
So yeah,
on the whole,
we think Witch Powers
were pretty good.
I love how flashy
they are in particular
and just how impactful
they look and feel.
Our team did a great job
with all of these.
Knocked it out of the park.
All right,
and with that in mind,
there's also still
one additional new Witch Power
that we did not have
on the PTR.
Oh, yes.
We've got the Force of Will.
Now this is a Psyche Witch Power
that empowers your overpowers.
When you kill an enemy,
your next overpower
is going to gain
some increased damage
up to a maximum.
And if you rank it up
to at least rank four,
it'll empower your next
two overpowers.
Excellent.
This was one that
we were not able
to get out on the PTR
in time.
It had some issues,
but it was being
in development.
But for the actual
season launch,
we're going to have this
out there and available.
We know it kind of
really rounds out the roster
of Witch Powers
that were available.
Yep.
We had, you know,
one less Psyche Power
than the others.
This is the last one.
And we didn't really have
too much support in there
for overpower builds.
And now we do.
Voila.
So really excited
about this one
and helped to empower
overpower.
All right.
So I think that wraps up
all of our balance changes.
Once again,
check out the patch notes
for the exact details.
But hope this, you know,
gets your minds turning
for build crafting
for next week
when the season launches.
Yeah, there is absolutely
a ton of chew on.
Like, I went into this stream
absolutely thinking
I was going to roll
Spiritborn again.
And now I'm thinking
I'm going to have to go
Barb or Shadow Clone Rogue.
Those are so sweet.
Got my decisions cut out
for me, that's for sure.
Absolutely.
And with the Armory,
you're going to be able to pick,
you know, one class
and a bunch of builds
from all of them.
Aislinn, I think,
what better thing
to get into now
than tell us about the Armory?
Oh, yeah,
I would love to.
Yeah.
So for those who don't know,
the Armory is a tool
that you can use
to basically save a loadout
that you've constructed.
So you're going to be able
to save your skills
that you've picked.
You're going to be able
to save the equipment
you've used.
You're going to be able
to save the Paragon points
you've put in.
And you're going to be able
to imprint it onto
one of these slots
in the Armory you see
on the left here
in this image.
Like, this character
has Crush Hand,
Touch of Death,
or Touch Death,
Quill, Razor Wings,
and Payback.
So, you know,
this is a Spiritborn
that has saved a bunch
of different builds there.
It's really wonderful
because, you know,
if you want to try
a different build,
like if you want to try
Touch of Death,
but you've spent
a really long time
working on Crushing Hand,
you don't have to worry
about changing all of that
manually anymore
with the Armory.
You can just do it
automatically.
Once you've created
that build,
you save it,
and then you can swap
to it whenever you want.
These loadout slots
are also character bound.
So, you know,
you make a Spiritborn,
and then you decide
you later want to swap
to a Necro or,
you know, whatever.
You're going to be able
to ensure that you have
a lot of variety
to play in each character class.
Another thing about loadouts
is that they don't
cause gold to change,
so you're not going to have
a bunch of significant
gold overhead
when you're actually
swapping these,
so you don't have to worry
about that at all,
which is very nice.
And the Armory
can be accessed
through a bunch of
different places
in Sanctuary as well,
including Major Cities,
the Dark Citadel,
the Tree of Whispers,
of course,
which is a major
focal point of Season 7,
and training areas,
so that if you're trying
to test certain things,
you can really easily
make adjustments
without having to,
you know,
spend a lot of time on that.
And finally,
we've got a few PTR updates
where we gathered feedback
from the PTR.
We have improved
the button clarity
from the PTR.
If you see in the image,
the little highlighted
white box section,
that should be more clear
than it was in the PTR.
And we heard you guys
about easier loadout deletion.
We're going to make sure
that that is much easier
to do in 2.11.
And next up,
we have some gameplay updates.
So these are just
some miscellaneous things
that are coming in Season 7
related to systemic gameplay.
So I'll just go through
these one by one here.
We have Paragon Migration.
So any experience
that you earn
on your Paragon levels
in the Seasonal Realm,
once the season is over,
are going to be added
to your Eternal Realm season,
rather,
your Eternal Realm Paragon level.
So if you earn
a bunch of Paragon XP
in Season 6,
and then Season 6 ends,
all of that Paragon XP
is going to be added
to your Eternal Paragon level,
which is going to make
reaching Paragon level 300
a lot more attainable
for a lot of folks
on the Eternal Realm,
which is pretty cool.
Yeah, you just get progress
every season over season
on your Eternal Realm Paragon
to make sure you can
really reach the heights of that,
even if you're just
a seasonal player
for the most part.
When you hop into Eternal Realm,
all of that progress
is going to be carried over.
Yeah, and it's actually
going to be really nice
because I think the way
I like to think about it
is even if you don't play
on the Eternal Realm,
it's kind of like a window
into how much you've played
the game
and how much effort
you've put in,
and you get to look
at that number
and be like,
oh, that just gets higher
and higher.
It's great.
Next up, we have
some unique power roll updates.
So something that you might notice
when you are finding unique items
is that if they roll Ancestral
and they drop with greater affixes,
that doesn't affect
the actual unique power roll
itself in any way.
So it was possible
to find, for example,
a three or four greater affix unique,
but then the actual power roll itself
min rolled.
And that could feel
pretty deflating.
Oh, yeah.
Because you would get really excited
that you found a unique
that you wanted
that had all the GAs
and then you look
and it doesn't actually
feel very usable
because the power roll itself
was very low.
We're changing this
in Season 7.
So now,
the power roll floor
changes based on the number
of greater affixes
that the unique has.
So the more greater affixes
it has,
the higher guaranteed roll
on the unique power
you're going to get.
So when you do see
that three or four greater
affix unique you want,
you know it's going
to absolutely slap,
which is awesome.
Yeah, definitely.
That was always a little bit
of a frustrating experience
when you get really excited
for an item drop
but then you're like,
well,
is it really better
than what I currently have?
You know,
you had to start,
stop and think about that
based on the affixes
and the unique power roll.
But now,
if you get a three or four GA,
hey,
you know it's going
to be powerful.
It may not be guaranteed
to be the best one
but it's going to be
one of the more powerful rolls.
Yeah, absolutely.
And next up,
we have some other
ancestral item changes.
So something you may have noticed
if you were playing
a lot of Season 6
is that ancestral items
are the only ones
that can have
the top aspect rolls.
And what that meant
was that
those ancestral items
were still rolling randomly.
So like,
let's just say
for the sake of argument
that a non-ancestral item
with an aspect
could roll up to rank 8
on that aspect.
But then the ancestral version
could roll up to rank 11.
That ancestral item
was still randomly,
like totally randomly rolling
among all the different ranks.
And that made it seem
really,
what didn't seem,
it was,
it was very rare
to find the top end
of these aspect rolls
which actually wasn't the case
in previous seasons.
And we were all feeling
that in Season 6.
And for the completionists
out there
and the people
who want to make sure
that they have
the best version
of the aspects
that they can,
we wanted to make sure
that we changed that.
So now when you find
these ancestral items,
they are going to gravitate
more towards the top end
of those aspect rolls.
And it should be much easier
to actually fill out
your collection of aspects
than it was before
in Season 6.
And then as just
a totally separate
but wonderful thing,
we were working on
like how often
ancestral items
should actually drop
as a baseline.
And we've just bumped
that up in Season 7.
So you should,
in general,
find more ancestral items
than you did before.
And this is like
a very,
something that feels
very small
but has a big impact
on the season
as a whole.
So that should feel
a lot better
in Season 7 as well.
And finally,
something else
that we were noticing
in Season 6
was that people
were finding
tons and tons
of gem fragments
and sometimes
even capping out
their gem fragments
if you've played enough.
And this problem
was exacerbated
in Season 6
and we want to make sure
that you have something
to do with those
gem fragments.
So we created
a gem fragment conversion
at the Jewel Crafter.
So we have a little clip
to just show
what that looks like here.
So we're in Zarbenzed
as a sorcerer
and we're next to the jeweler.
We're going to talk to them.
There's a little tab
where you can go
to Jewelry Crafting.
And once you're
in the late game
and you've already crafted
all your grand gems
and you don't actually
have much to do
with your gem fragments anymore,
now you can just
directly convert them
into jewelry.
So you can craft rings
and you can craft amulets
and it will give you
a little cash
that will have
a randomly rolled item.
And this is just,
again, you know,
it's a nice dump basically
once you want to just,
once you finish
all your grand gems
and you just want to
find some extra gear.
And these can roll
as ancestral items,
which is wonderful.
And amulets and rings
can, you know,
they have a wide range
of potentially useful stats.
And so being able
to just roll those more
is really nice
because you can actually
target farm the things
you need.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Really excited for that.
Yep, for sure.
And finally,
we have some
kind of more quality
of life centered
or early game updates
that should be really nice
going forward
season over season.
season.
So now that we're
in season seven
of Diablo 4,
it's possible
that you may have
made a character
of any given class
and you might be
doing it again.
And it's not always
the most fun
to go through
the same content
over and over.
And so because of that,
we wanted to make sure
that you didn't actually
have to do
your class quest
to unlock
your class mechanic
every single time
you make a new character.
So for example,
if you made a sorcerer
and you unlocked
enchantments previously,
you're not actually
going to have to
do that again.
So when you hit
level 15 on a new sorcerer
in any realm,
you're immediately
going to unlock
an enchantment slot
because the game knows
that you already
did that before.
You can, however,
still do the class quest
if you would like,
but you do not have to.
And again,
just to reiterate,
you do have to do
the class quest
at least once
on any character
and then on your account,
it's unlocked forever.
And to go along
with this change,
we have a new cache
that we like to call
archetype cache
or archetype caches rather.
So these are basically
themed goodie bags.
So they come from
a variety of sources.
You're going to get
an archetype cache
when you complete
the class quest.
You're going to get them
periodically over the
course of the season journey
from different chapters.
And then eventually
you're going to start
earning greater archetype
caches as well,
which have better stuff.
But we have a clip here
to basically just show off
what an archetype cache
looks like
and what doing your
class quest looks like
in season seven.
So we have a level 15
sorcerer here
who's just going to go
and do their class quest,
which is the legacy
of the Magi over here.
And the reason
that this character
might want to do
the class quest still,
even though let's assume
that they have already
made a sorcerer
and have already
unlocked their enchantment,
is because they're going
to be getting
an archetype cache.
So we're going to go through,
we're just going to do
all of the stuff
for Legacy of the Magi,
get through the dungeon.
But then at the end,
we're going to get
an archetype cache.
And archetype caches
have items
and a tempering manual
that are relevant
to a specific theme
of any given class.
And so I'm glad
we have sorcerer here
because the sorcerer themes
are very straightforward.
For example,
pyromancy or fire
is one of the themes
in sorcerer.
So here we see
we have a pyromancy cache
that we got from completing
the class quest.
We're going to open it up.
It's got two legendary items,
a tempering manual,
and some extra materials
like bundled herbs
and angel breath,
and et cetera.
Because it was a pyromancy cache,
it came with a utility
and a more offensive-focused
legendary
that are related
to being a pyromancy sorcerer.
It also came with
a pyromancy-related
tempering manual.
So that really helps you
get started on your journey
as like a fire sorcerer.
So if you find something like that,
you're right out of the gate
at level 15,
you're going to get
a big jump in power,
and you're going to be able
to dive into like
what it means to be
a fire sorcerer
pretty quickly.
Yeah, I think what I really like
about this change
is that, you know,
if you're just playing
a new character,
you're in the flow,
you're doing the head hunts,
you're leveling up,
you ding,
hit level 15, right?
You think,
oh, now I've got to go
do this quest,
otherwise I'm missing out
on power.
And sometimes, you know,
you're in that flow.
You don't want to stop
and change,
shift gears,
and go do that class quest.
You now can do it
on your own time, right?
You can instantly unlock
that power
from the class mechanic,
and then whenever
you get a chance,
whenever you think,
hey, I want to go
do this quest,
you can go do it
and then feel rewarded
for getting a nice
archetype cache
that really maybe
pushes you in a certain direction
if you're unsure
of how you want to
build your character,
can help to enhance,
you know,
the pyromancy,
like you mentioned.
Yep, or frost,
or lightning,
or, you know,
every class has its own themes,
so it's going to be fun
to dig into that.
Cool.
All right.
That's awesome.
Yeah, I think even
for that early game too,
when you're kind of
scrounging for materials
and uniques,
it is kind of difficult
to hit that next power level,
so knowing that you have
a guaranteed,
now optional,
quest to go to
to get that power in.
I can speak for Twitch that too.
They were very, very excited
to see that you did
not have to do
the class quest anymore,
but that it gives you
this optional power boost
in a certain direction.
We wanted to make sure
that it wasn't worthless
if you had already done it a lot.
We wanted to make sure
that there was still
something there
to feel like
it was a meaningful quest.
Yeah, but not so good
that you feel like
you're missing out
if you're...
Exactly.
Taking care of things
over in the headhunts
and things like that.
Yep.
Well, that brings us
to our Q&A portion of the stream.
So we're going to bring
Dan Tangway back
and we're going to answer
some of your hard-hitting questions.
So thank you for everyone
who dropped questions
in Twitch chat
throughout the stream.
I've also been laughing
at your commentary throughout.
It's been pretty good.
So first off,
I want to drop a question
from Doggo.
Asked,
will there be a mid-season patch
with balance changes?
Yeah, I can talk about that.
We are currently planning
to have a mid-season
balance patch
like we do every season.
I just want to reiterate
some of the philosophy
around mid-season patches
as well.
For our mid-season patches,
we're mainly looking
at taking the data
from when the season launches.
So honestly,
we haven't started looking
at the mid-season patch at all
because it's so heavily driven
by what actually happens
when the season launches.
What builds are performing well?
What builds are not performing well?
If there's anything
that is bugged
or broken to the point
where it's trivializing the game,
that might be something
we look at.
In general,
for mid-season patches
that happen,
well,
in the middle of the season,
we're primarily looking
to bring up
the underperformers
or fix issues
of interactions
that maybe aren't
quite seeing the spotlight
that we were expecting them to.
We're not really looking
to take the top builds
and nerf them.
Right.
Because we know players
have already had time
to invest in their characters.
They've got the gear.
They've leveled it up.
They've read build guides
like,
hey,
how do I make this character?
And we feel like
if we're taking those down
in the middle of a season,
that really does a disservice
to players
that you are afraid
of making the powerful thing
because it might get nerfed
in the mid-season.
So that's something we avoid.
There are, of course,
sometimes rare exceptions
when they're so far above
our power bar
or they are literally
breaking the game
due to performance-related issues
which occasionally pop up.
Those things we still
will address
when we need to.
But in general,
mid-season patches
are not for nerfing
strong builds
if they are just strong.
And that's partly why
during Season 6
we knew that, you know,
Spiritborn was
a very powerful class.
Like, no kidding around it.
It was definitely stronger
than the other classes
on Season 6.
But that was okay.
We didn't want to make
any kind of
snap judgment of like,
oh, we need to nerf it
here in mid-season.
We know players
have been invested into it
and we want to respect
their time and investment
into that.
It's important that there's
a sense of security
in picking a build
and knowing that it is
going to stay viable
when you're playing it
throughout the season.
Yeah, and kind of
as a corollary to that,
whenever we do
seasonal updates
like launch a brand new season,
that is more
when we're going to look
and say, hey,
what is dramatically
overperforming?
What is crowding out
the rest of the roster?
Like Spiritborn
during Season 6
was maybe crowding out
some of the other classes.
We take the seasonal resets
as a time to say,
that's when we're going
to bring those builds down
and that's when everyone
is starting fresh
on the new season
and so you're not losing
that much of time investment
if it's starting
all fresh again.
Yeah, and on the system side
in terms of mid-season changes,
it's really important to us
that we have a very targeted approach
to systemic changes
in mid-season patches.
We want to make sure
that we are gathering
as much data as possible
and as much information
as we can
to ensure that any tweaks
we make aren't going
to cause waves
or changes
that we weren't expecting
or undesirable.
So we really want to gather
as much telemetry
and data as possible
from how people
are actually experiencing
this season
and then kind of patch
those pain points
that we all find together
and we want to wait
to make sure
that we're doing it right.
So we really want to know
how people are going
to be playing
Season of the Witchcraft
and then we'll basically
figure out
what needs to happen
and change from there.
Yeah, and that's why
so much of the feedback
from PTR
or even just throughout
the regular seasons,
all the feedback,
we really do listen to it
and it's so important to us
to make sure
that we can make
Diablo 4 as best
as we possibly can.
It's really critical
that we get that feedback
and we're able
to iterate on that.
Absolutely.
Awesome.
That is a super thorough answer
for the mid-season patch.
I mean, like,
I'll take all the information
you got,
so that's fantastic.
This one's probably
for you, Aislinn,
from, oh boy, okay,
bear with me here.
Pap, Pap, Surup, Sagan,
do the Class Quest caches
scale to the level
when they're opened?
Oh, yes,
they absolutely do.
So you can get it early
or you can get it later,
but the archetype caches
that you find
in the Class Quest
aren't actually the only place
you can find archetype caches.
You're going to be able
to get more from
the season journey
and other sources as well.
So they're not exactly,
like, a super finite supply,
so you don't have to think
too hard about, like,
exactly when you should
be opening them.
The Class Quest
is just one among
many sources
that you can earn
in archetype cache.
So you don't have to, like,
sit on it throughout
the whole season
to be like,
all right,
when am I going to pop
this thing?
Yeah.
And nice to have
some extra goodies
as you're on your way
to get a Dorian the Raven.
Of course.
Because we know
that's the most important thing.
I mean,
I don't want to say,
but Dorian's pretty cool.
Also, on a similar thread,
the Collector Casey asks,
is the Class Quest unlock
retroactive
as of right now
or only after
we complete it
this season?
Yeah, so as long,
it's retroactive.
So as long as
you've completed,
you know,
you've done
the Sorcerer quest before
on a Sorcerer
at any point during Diablo,
you're good to go.
Nice.
From the Discord,
Bacterial,
cool name,
can we expect
the summon tag
to work with
minion thorns
and any update
on Bristleback aspect
working with minions?
I believe they should.
I'd have to look
into precisely
minion thorns.
I know that was
a stat that,
you know,
your summons
can inherit your thorns.
That was a stat
that I,
hmm,
I'd have to look
into exactly
Bristleback aspect,
but as a general matter,
our philosophy
on minion thorns
and minions
in general
is if you think
it should work,
it should.
The interactions
of when you deal
thorns damage,
it should,
if your minions
are the ones
triggering that thorns damage,
it should count
as if you had dealt it.
I don't have that
right in front of me,
that particular interaction,
but that is our philosophy
and if that's not happening,
then we'll look
to address it
and improve that
moving forward.
Cool.
Thank you.
I just had a question
from
AoE Alina.
Are there plans
to reduce visual clutter
such as an opacity slider?
I love Sorcerer
and Spiritborn,
but the visual effects
are hindering my party.
I think that would
probably be something
that we would have
to talk to the UI team
about and the folks
over in VFX.
It's something
that we've been grappling
with throughout
the life of Diablo
because, you know,
there's so much happening,
especially when you have
an endgame build.
And, you know,
if that gets so out of hand
with new seasonal mechanics
or new powers
or legendary aspects
that we create,
it's something
that we'll be taking a look at
every time something
like that comes up.
Yeah.
I totally get it too
because when you're
playing Spiritborn,
you know what to look for
as you're casting
these abilities,
but if you're just around it,
then it can be
a little overwhelming.
Like when I have friends
that come by
that perhaps haven't played
a Diablo game before,
they're like,
how do you know
what to look at?
It's like you just
kind of figure it out.
But I can totally see
how that could be
a bit of a distraction
on the screen.
Ooh, Anjinsan.
For the Q&A,
how do hydras work
with the new summoning changes
and how does burning damage
work in comparison to poison?
Yeah.
Another very technical question
for you, Charles.
So luckily,
you know,
I did include
the Sorcerer Conjurations
in the summons update
when I talked about them.
Yeah.
But actually,
for the most part,
the Conjurations
were already behaving this way.
And that was part
of the inconsistency
that I kind of
had glossed over,
said, hey,
they were inconsistent.
And, you know,
since now we're
in the more technical part,
the inconsistency was that
most of the Sorcerer Conjurations
were already behaving
the way that we wanted them to.
Right.
Where the damage
was being attributed
to the player,
and it was actually
the Necro minions
and Shadow Clone
and Druid Companions
primarily that were
not as interactive
as we would have liked.
Right.
So with that in mind,
there's actually
no real functional changes
to the way
that Hydra works with this.
I don't believe Hydra
was really touched,
but it was actually used
as kind of the example
of how we wanted
to implement
and make the other summons work.
One question I do want
to take really quickly
that I've seen throughout chat,
I mean,
it was really hard to ignore.
People are asking
where Adam was.
I mean,
I think we just have
to address it straight up.
Adam Fletcher
is no longer with Blizzard,
which is really too bad.
So you won't really
be seeing him
in a whole lot
of other streams.
So really sorry
to disappoint chat,
but you're stuck with him.
Just kidding.
He's been here
the whole time.
Oh my God.
Just kidding.
Adam's staying forever.
Is Adam in the room
with us right now?
He has been here
the whole time.
Yeah,
yeah.
To be clear,
Adam has literally sat
two feet to the left
this entire time
just like for the whole stream.
Just hanging out,
checking out,
watching chat.
So yeah,
Adam,
Adam is here to stay.
Do not worry.
All right.
Love from Judith.
Stash space is already
a problem for anyone
running multiple characters.
Are there any plans
to change armory loadouts
so that they will not
be stored in stash?
You know,
it's something,
the armory is very new.
We knew that the community
really,
really wanted the armory
and so we wanted to
get out a version of it
that we,
you know,
was serviceable
to get started.
But we know it's a really,
really important topic
for the community.
So it's something
that we're going to
continuously look at
and we're going to be
looking a lot at feedback
on the armory
to make sure that it's
as smooth as possible
all the time.
And to that end,
you know,
we will be taking
that into consideration.
No concrete plans
right now,
but it's something,
you know,
it's one of the topics
that we have.
And our,
again,
our ultimate goal
is to make the armory
just basically
the most streamlined
version of itself
that it can be.
So look for armory
improvements in the future
for sure.
Awesome.
Cool.
And we got our last
question from the Q&A.
This is actually a two-parter
for both of you.
We have Poseidon Bobby
was asking Charles,
does your shirt
glow in the dark?
You know,
I haven't tried,
but it looks like it might.
It looks like it might.
It looks like it should.
At least if you might
glow in the dark bowling
for sure would light up.
I am being told it doesn't
and I demand a refund.
Wow.
I would like to get
a glow in the dark
Lilith shirt now.
What a ripoff, man.
And then on a similar vein,
Aislinn,
Radiobiology was asking,
can you buy that sweater?
Can you buy this wonderful
holiday Lilith's
Christmas sweater?
I don't know.
Adam is saying it's sold out.
It's sold out.
It's sold out for a year.
Sold out for every year.
This is a one-of-a-kind.
We did have a different
holiday sweater this past year,
so there should,
I mean,
hopefully be another
holiday sweater next year.
No guarantees.
Yeah.
But yeah,
if you do see those
holiday sweaters in the shop,
get them before they're gone.
There's always like
really wonderful merch online
for Diablo.
I love taking a look at it,
so if you like Diablo merch
and you want something like this,
definitely, you know,
check it periodically.
Definitely grab it.
Well, yeah,
that brings us to the end
of the stream.
I want to give a really big
thank you to Aislinn,
Charles,
Dan Tanguay.
Thank you so much
for hanging out with us
all the way in snowy
Albany, New York.
I hope it's not too
terribly cold.
Not too bad.
Okay, okay.
Glad to hear it.
I have to say that room
looks freezing.
It's like a dungeon.
It does look very cold.
It's a little chilly.
Yeah.
But I got my jacket on.
I'm all right.
Good.
Nice.
Glad to hear it.
But yeah,
thank you all for joining us
and Twitch,
YouTube,
TikTok,
everyone,
thank you for staying tuned
and checking out
everything that's to come
with Season of Witchcraft.
Like we mentioned
throughout the stream,
Patch Notes will be dropping
after the stream.
We did have our blog
that launched on Tuesday
as well.
Also,
I got to give a massive
shout out again
to our production team.
There's a lot of faces
you don't see
that put a ton of blood,
sweat, and tears
into the show.
These heads are
absolutely disgusting
and I don't know
if anybody needs
more of a reason
to brush your teeth,
but you know,
don't end up
looking like that guy.
No.
Season of Witchcraft
does start on January 21st
at 10 a.m. PST,
so be sure to go in.
And for anyone
who hasn't yet completed
your Season Journey,
your Battle Pass,
check your Seasonal Stash
or Eternal Stash as well
before those items disappear.
But yeah,
we got Season of Witchcraft
on January 21st.
Super excited to get into it.
Thank you from all of us
here at Blizzard
and we will see you
at the Tree of Whispers.
Thanks, guys.
You're welcome.